there is a woman out there
who is sexually attracted to airplanes
and she wants to marry
a toy bowing can we scroll through tyler
to some of the images because it's truly
remarkable to see this is a real story
this is from the new york post look at
what's happening here there's a bit of
intimacy
that you can see a hug
yep
wants to marry the airplane look there
she is
carry on you can carry on i don't know
if there's oh wait the boeing is named
dicky the boeing is named dickie which
um i'm not gonna go there
i'm not gonna go there ty i know you
want me to
i'm not gonna go there even though
you're you're you're beckoning me forth
um she identifies as objectum sexual
i tell you okay there you go there it is
okay so there
there's a lot going on there is all i'm
gonna say for a second wow i was
confused i thought that was legs it's
not it's the wings of the plane i was
very confused this is what happens when
the article doesn't pull up on my
computer
so listen um
first of all
this is fascinating to me
i've never met a person who was
attracted to an inanimate object in that
way
i find it interesting that it's an
airplane we had a little discussion
about this before the show does it
matter if the plane is filled with
people does that
complicate matters what if you're
attracted to some of the people on the
plane but not others i don't know is she
talking about a real airplane like is it
only a miniature airplane
is it a life-size airplane
there's a lot of questions i have
can you be attracted to an inanimate
object is a fascinating i would love to
talk to someone robin booking can you
hear me wherever you are let's get
someone on
audience is like jed no really imagine
talking to someone
that
is attracted i would like to know how
does that wedding go how intimate does
it get and what does that look like
audience at home you know you want to
know
i may be the one saying it and
embarrassing myself right now tyler is
like
but you know you want to know
i need the details
tyler does as well what do you think
tyler is this real or is this fake is
this just a plea for attention or do you
think there are people out there well i
i think it's a plea for attention
certainly but i also think people are
cuckoo bananas
yeah and that brings up another point
like
i'm a live and let live type of person
i've said that before i'm like hey
you know what you wanna
you wanna marry an airplane
i don't know if you can even make that
happen but you wanna bond with an
airplane in ways that maybe i don't want
to
you do you
but at some point um we do have to say
like is this a mentally well person
what's going on here and where we talk
about slippery slopes and that i don't
know where this lands i'm scared to ask
no pun intended
exactly scared to ask where it lands
scared to ask what comes next scared to
ask what other objects could be
think about it
or don't if you like the short clip you
can catch another one here or you can
catch the full episode right here
[Music]